hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and uh hahaha I'm checking in on
you
how are you oh I'm sweating my
balls off here in [__] New York City
Jesus Christ the last two times I came
to New York I really I actually was just
like you know I could live back here I
like this this is [__] nice no
came back
with this [__] [__]
I don't know what happened to my
I used to stay in this part of the city
all the time I cannot even tell you how
many [__] rats were running down the
street the amount of goddamn [__]
people that go dude what's going on in
L.A because all they show in La is a
bunch of homeless people stabbing each
other I'm not saying that isn't
happening
but that that is not indicative of what
goes on when you walk down the [__]
Street
um they immediately go to downtown L.A
they immediately go to the worst thing
I'm just on a random [__] Street dude
the streets were alive with the sounds
of rats
running down the [__] Street like the
only thing that was missing was that
[__] jerk off with with the flute
walking him out of town into the into
the East River or something
um I was hanging out with my buddy last
night right
I was on [__] West Coast time we were
sitting in this little Park that I used
to sit in all the time not even it was a
more of like a
Ted concrete but you know it's a place
where they actually put benches and they
actually let you sit down one of those
places
and uh
there was so many [__] rats
on the goddamn sidewalk I mean granted
the trash was out but I lived in this
neighborhood back in the day
there was nothing like this like
even the crazy homeless people were
[__] walking down the middle of the
street they were yelling at the rats but
they were like I am not [__]
I'm not going anywhere near those things
I don't know
kind of I like you know it's a good
thing liking where you're at
um so anyway I am uh I got a show
tonight in Allentown
I was in a Billy Joel one right any
place you go in Pennsylvania you know
there's some sort of Rust Belt that guy
wrote a song about it you know
say goodbye to Upper Darby
I know that's in uh Philadelphia
whatever I'm in a grumpy [__] move
because I forgot today was Thursday and
I already did a podcast
for somebody else and I thought my
podcasting was over I'd also not had
um
a cup of coffee right so I mean I'm kind
of losing it with this you know the
first 10 days of every [__] month
I [__] it up last month because it was
my birthday I was like ah you know blah
blah
and uh you know I did well for like five
days
I started on June 30th
then July 4th I'm like what what am I
who am I you know
some guy with [__] freckles on his
balls I'm not gonna uh
you know smoke a cigar on the gel on on
the on the July 4th on July 4th
so I did that
and then I came to the city last night
and I hit up a buddy of mine
and I sat in a rat infested [__]
block
and smoked another one I'm just like
what am I doing
then I'm walking around out there in the
heat
trying to find a cigar and it's [__]
hilarious like nobody sells cigars but
everybody sells Vape weed and and and
whatever else they got going on in there
it's kind of funny those uh
those weed and vape stores I don't get
like why is it like so
why do they come with the Tokyo Vibe you
know you ever see like pictures of Tokyo
it looks amazing like it looks like
Times Square you know
but these [__] you know but it makes
sense because every everywhere over
there
at least the pictures I've seen
is kind of what this the city looks like
so if I'm gonna use this word it fits in
with the aesthetic whoa
that's a [__] 18 word right there it
fits in with the aesthetic
these [__] weed vape stores they're
just next to sort of these Bland things
and then they just got like these all
these just
it's like a [__] tropical fish tank
like come on in and get your drugs man
um
so we you know we kept going into this
place you got any cigars and I said yeah
but they had the ones that you know the
kids buy and take the tobacco out make a
blunt out of it
which you know
people say this younger generation
doesn't want to work but you know when
they these younger kids could easily buy
a pre-rolled joint and they're still
taking the time
foreign
buy a bad cigar
crack it open and I still don't quite
understand how that works
I've watched people do it but I just
don't I feel like once you break the
leaf like how do you get it back
together
and then it's just oh you just I just
sort of lick all up and down the [__]
shaft
it's great and then what I'm gonna smoke
that day [__] it no
let me get the pre-rolled one
that the AI robot [__] licked on with
its with its fake tongue with the
synthetic saliva
um
anyway
somebody sent me this piece on uh
Robert Kennedy Jr
uh
the left is already depicting him
as a conspiracy conspiracy theorist
lunatic
um so you know what that means that
means he's good for the people he's not
good for the banks and the [__] the
war guys
you know
like I I don't they do this the
Democrats do this every [__] election
you know and they're gonna [__]
they're gonna they're gonna do a big hit
piece on him they're gonna [__] trash
them they're gonna ignore the fact that
the guy works for a non-profit and
[__] uh
holds corporations accountable for
polluting the water they're going to
ignore all of that [__] they get the
guy's out of his mind
he's into shape shifters no he's saying
isn't he saying that like he doesn't
believe the Warren Commission I mean
that's not too [__] crazy is it
he doesn't believe
Sirhan Saran acted alone I can count
with that
I love how he's a conspiracy theorist
but I can just because I'm not running
for office I can say the NBA is fixed
but people don't walk around
you know right now you know they'll
trash my comedy but they don't say I'm a
conspiracy theory lunatic theorist
lunatic or whatever they always [__]
do this
anytime there's somebody for the for the
you know I'm not saying who's the best
guy or whatever but like I love when
they do that
you know
um and look you expect it from the right
because this guy's a lefty but when the
left is doing it that's when you're like
ah
so you don't want me to pick him
I see what's going on here
I see what's going on so I'm gonna pick
that guy
all right because I'm a rebel you know I
just bought a new black leather jacket
and I'm going to put the collar up and I
don't give a [__] that it's
the hottest July 4th
in modern history or whatever the [__]
they said all that scary [__] whatever
we're gonna we know we're gonna figure
it out
we're gonna figure it out somehow that's
what you got to keep saying to yourself
we're gonna figure this [__] out
by staying the course
and acting like everything's okay and
then we when we can no longer deny that
everything is not okay we will then
waste time blaming each other
all right and then Billy Joel will write
a song called We Didn't Start to Fire
and then then that's it and we'll just
move forward
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry I'm a little heat exhausted here
um anyway I'm really looking forward to
these shows I read this book
I gotta I gotta tell you guys
every once in a while you know I read a
book and then when I read a book I never
shut up about it do I because I'm so
proud of myself that I actually [__]
read a book
I'd be more proud of myself if I could
find my my little backpack my pack for
backing
I thought it was literally was next to
me
on the Davenport here I'm staring into
my age using old people words
get your feet off the Davenport
and look at you look at you go put on
some clean clothes you got stuff all
over your trousers
[__] is the goddamn book
you [__]
it's Man's Search for for meaning
I think
Victor Frankel
so it was about this
this doctor Jewish guy the guy survives
for uh concentration camps
and then finds meaning
in his suffering
in order to be able to move forward dude
some of the quotes in this [__] book
he said there's only two races of men
decent men and not decent men and every
group
has both so there's no such thing as a
pure race
and he also said
no man has the right to hurt another man
even if he was hurt
just [__] like that it's just like Jesus
Christ
I never looked at it that way you know
man I approached the world as a sports
fan
um
but he he finds purpose and suffering
and all that it was [__] amazing
uplifting book
in a quick book it's only like 150 pages
right so you know you know that's right
up my alley you know my only complaint
the book not enough pictures
[Laughter]
[Music]
but uh so I go to his Wikipedia page and
of course like his contemporaries have
to take the piss out of him
going like well you know he wasn't
really an out he was only an out switch
for four days it's like that's four days
too many in my world it's four days more
than me and then those other ones he
wasn't
it's like it had to be the most [__]
[__] thing I ever read
well he wasn't announcement really
are you out of your [__] mind
the guy lost his wife
the love of his [__] life
he was tortured he wasn't fed and all
that he figured out a [__] way how to
survive it you're gonna [__] nitpick
that
unreal man
is it unreal I guess it isn't I guess
there's always going to be that you know
comic has a great special there'll be
some he's not that funny all he's doing
is this
you know I guess I get that with the
pettiness of of show business or
whatever and even politics but you gotta
think
you know if you went to uh numerous
concentration camps people wouldn't
nitpick your [__] stats this other
guy goes actually the real hero of the
book is actually him
I'm not gonna lie to you after a while
towards the end I was saying this guy's
kind of gassing up his his uh his new uh
he came up with this new [__] uh
therapy
so he was definitely selling it but you
know
I'm selling my [__] right we all are
you know like I drag you know
house [__] [__] something something
you know
Billy Joel can write a song about it so
I was just in a car and that song came
on
as the funniest lyric I've ever heard
trouble in the sewers
it doesn't really rhyme with anything
and I've always been meaning to look up
what the trouble in the zoo is that's
one of those songs that people who
aren't Baby Boomers [__] can't stand
because it sounds like Baby Boomers
whining and then when you go to the
video it's only baby boomers watching
the song and they're all just sitting
there going like oh my God like Billy
Joel could give like a [__] history
lesson it's just like he's not giving a
history lesson
if I just say Watergate I can say
Watergate World War II the Industrial
Revolution I haven't said [__]
anything about him have I
I can't come at Billy Joel he seems like
he went to summer school like me right
so I got to stick he did the work come
on pass them
um
Bill are you riffing about a Billy Joel
song from [__] 30
four years ago yes I am
I live in 1989. it's my safe space
that's where I live my best life that
was another thing I got out of the book
too was he was he was talking about
how finding true happiness is is
you know
it's basically the opposite of what
they're selling us I know this is really
old and really [__] hacky but uh
you just I see it all the time on uh
like Instagram and I give into it
you know what I mean like ah look at
that car man
I wish I had that car what if I was in
that car and I was driving down the
street people saw me in that car what
they think
wow
look at that old bald orange man in that
car
out of all the old bald orange men out
there he's probably got to be the
coolest old bald orange man coming down
the [__] Street you know I I give
into that [__] and uh
he was just talking about
you know the the purpose
of a man is to help other people and
ease their pain and it gets you out of
your own [__] you're able to [__]
move forward and however you choose to
do that it was pretty profound at least
for me it was
you know
I'm sure somebody's going to write in
and [__]
break my balls about it you know
actually uh do you know that guy uh
you know they always come up with
something either sexual or uh stealing
money
um anyway
all I know is that guy was Skin and
Bones coming out of a concentration camp
and he still lived to be 92 and he takes
you through
did I even already talk about this
that's that's the catchphrase on this
podcast did I already talked about this
he takes you through the three levels of
going to a concentration camp the first
was the disbelief that you were there
then the settling in the numbness of it
then uh
uh the disbelief I guess when you're
free
slash the guilt
when you don't really feel Joy because
you've lost the ability you've so numbed
yourself to feeling anything just so you
can survive
um
I don't know oh geez now they're making
me feel like the guy was saying he was
he was kind of being the hero of the
book because they get out of the
concentration camp
and he's walking with this other
prisoner and they get to this farm and
the guy's just
trouncing the crops walking across them
and the author's going hey man don't
step on that because he's like why the
[__] do I give a [__] about this
[Laughter]
you know
I just had four [__] years of my life
taken away I lost all my [__]
relatives you're gonna give a [__] about
these snow peas
and then the author's like hey man like
you know these snow peas you know
somebody planted these blood somehow he
was able to maintain
um his dignity in it and even if he
exaggerated it was very uh
very uplifting book
and those uplifting books they're fun to
read but then it's it's hard to apply it
in life
you know what I mean because you just
sit there and you walk down the street
and then you got this goofy smile on
your face and then the person walking
towards you think there's something
wrong with you
you know
you kind of have to be a little guarded
you can't be walking around like hey how
are you people start looking at you like
I'm good what what's your [__] deal
like what do you want
what are you trying to sell me
nothing at all I just read an
inspirational book well that's good why
don't you take that book and shove it up
your [__] ass all right and back to
reality evidently we are back outside
again
um
so anyway I got Allentown tonight say
goodbye to Ellen 10 or whatever the [__]
he thinks
um
in town Gettysburg Pittsburgh
Philadelphia
Lake Erie Buffalo [__] Rochester
I [__] ate my balls at every comedy
club in the [__] East Coast
that'd be funny to [__] sing that
song Just name and all the clubs you
bombed at
Go Bananas Carolines Rascals Stress
Factory
comic strip [__] seller Boston comedy
Bill are you losing your mind by
yourself yes I am
I am because as much as I'm [__] on
New York I do [__] love it
and I do miss it
and uh this little hotel Boutique
Boutique Boutique Hotel that I'm staying
at if they had a rooftop deck right now
I would go up there I would go up there
and I would look at the city
and I don't know what it is so the city
is still exciting to me
to be here and be like you know what
this is [__] amazing that I'm here
and then a rat runs across your foot and
you're like I gotta get the [__] out of
here
this is like a bad 80s jokes but there
were so many [__] rats last night I
was like relieved to see a roach
I was hanging out with Josh Adam Meyers
and I was like that [__] roach is the
most comforting thing I've seen in the
last 40 minutes
like dude I swear to God when the [__]
hits the fan New Yorkers are not gonna
starve
there are enough [__] rats fat
[__] rats these rats are [__]
living
I was so [__] annoyed with the amount
of rats on the street there was actually
one in this box with this stupid gray
furry ass up in the air and I [__]
kicked the box and another one ran out
right by my leg and I'm like what the
[__] am I doing
I had high tops on
oh man I would just love to go down the
street
with a [__] BB gun with CO2 and just
like that's what they need to do but
people aren't responsible enough like
that's what all these guys that play
[__] paint gun
you know you bring them in there you pay
them a nominal fee per 100 rats that
they [__] kill
oh
they would have a [__] ball
they get to dress up like army guys and
pretend they're in Special Forces and
then you send them down the [__]
subway tracks
and they feel like they're in Delta
Force
they did this you get those [__]
[__] down on Wall Street to do that
they'd be down there with their
manicured [__] nails
you know
with like probably equipment even better
you know than what the [__] Navy
Seals have because you know they their
their clients are the [__] Illuminati
oh geez Bill you're just going all over
the place with this Sonia yeah yeah
I think I am I think I is
um
and just having [__] just kill a
bunch of them
don't kill all of them because they must
serve a purpose
you know what I mean
they are a part of nature but they are
[__] they're you know they're running
wild this Saturday night
um
so anyway I got I got two new [__]
bits
two new ideas
two new ideas that I want to [__] try
and uh I'm gonna see how I'm doing
tonight like if I get on stage and I'm
feeling it
you know if the [__] knock-knock
jokes are flowing through me
I am 100 percent
going to uh
I'm gonna try but if it isn't
if it's feeling a little tight you know
like Tom Cruise that's no good it's no
good [__] shoot the goddamn Guy Tom
look at Tom Cruise again again he's got
another one
wait is he our country's Jackie Chan as
far as like doing stunts
but I feel like Jackie Chan was always
getting hurt
you know what I mean like breaking his
ankle and then [__] rubbing his
forehead and [__] Jackie Jackie Chan
took some [__] bumps but Tom Cruise
you see that [__] picture of him
sitting on just sitting on top of that
building
that smile on his face like he's on a
park bench feeding pigeons
it's it's unbelievable
it's [__] unbelievable
um
there's no way that guy has life
insurance there's just no [__] way
or what is his premium
you know what I mean
so what do you like to do uh my own
stunts could you describe him well this
next movie they're gonna duct tape me to
the side of an airplane
and it's going to take off and fly the
pattern oh yeah
is that it nope
I'm also going to learn how to fly an
a-star nose it down
um
I feel like he he does like a Red Bull
stunt every [__] movie now it's it's
fantastic and dare I say the man is
single-handedly
saving
like people going out to the movies
Top Gun now he's got like [__] uh
Mission Impossible part 19 coming out
like you're not gonna go see that you're
gonna go see that
um ah [__] I gotta go down
my rides here to go to Allentown I'll
finish this in Allentown
all right I'm back I'm not waiting till
Allentown
I'm gonna finish this I figured out they
did have actually roof access so now I'm
sitting here Up on the Roof didn't bring
my sunglasses so I might sneeze a couple
times like Christ who broke this table
can't have anything nice
somebody breaks it they don't [__]
say anything they don't give a [__]
what have you said something bill
I'd like to think I would
oh you the hero of this novel Bill are
you the guy saying don't step on the
snow piece
[__] it's bright out here
it's a weird part of the city
a bunch of new [__] hang on
that's going to get me kicked off surf
there's no sneezing up here
um
anyway
um I kind of forgot I had to do a
podcast today because I I went up and I
did uh Chas palmettiere's podcast
was an absolute thrill to meet him
got to talk to him uh
I was so amazed that I was actually
honest thing that I didn't ask him
enough questions
about uh
A Bronx Tale the only thing I talked
about was I talked about how much I
loved that bus that Robert De Niro was
driving because it had all those [__]
extra windows now they don't build [__]
like that anymore out of all the [__]
things I could have asked him
that's what I asked him
you know
that movie still had it has one of my
favorite cars of all [__] time
was a 66 or a 67 Cadillac Coupe Deville
with the forehead lights you know two on
each side stacked up on each on top of
each other
he had one [__] fire engine red
he just backs it up to his hideout
oh
someday
no I'm not gonna own one I'm gonna rent
them that's my new [__]
my my lovely wife cured me of that
thinking I had to own these cars I don't
need to own these cars I just need to
find someone who has them and drive them
for a weekend
you know
or what you do is you're that guy you
have one you're driving around for a
little bit you sell it you get something
else then you sell that but my thing is
I immediately fall in love with [__] and
then I want to redo the whole thing and
fix the whole [__] thing
and then you know keep it under a tarp
and all of that [__] I you know
I'm like a chick whose dad didn't stick
around you know just falling in love
with every sailor that comes down the
street
[Music]
40s
it's the Boogie we'll give you
[__] reads here
The Andrews Sisters
if you're wondering that was a big thing
The Mills Brothers The Andrews Sisters
there's a lot of uh
everybody thinks the Jacksons were the
first ones you know or the uh who's who
the Mormon wants
the osments nope Mills Brothers Andrews
Sisters
the Kowalski twins all right I made that
last one up all right Simply Safe
everybody you know when an intruder
threatens your home every second counts
yeah I would agree with that I just
picturing
somebody push against against the doors
the guy's coming through like Jack
Nicholson in The Shining go out the back
[Laughter]
why I am so excited to tell you about
the latest Innovation from Simply Safe
home security it's called 24 7 live
guard protection and it's made possible
only by simplisafe's new Smart Alarm
Wireless indoor cameras now with the
fast product monitoring plan if an
intruder breaks into your home Simply
Safe monitoring agents can actually see
speak to and deter them through the
camera
hey what the [__] are you doing wow
warning them that they're being recorded
and that the police are on their way
it's a game changer in home security
well yeah that would that would freak
anybody out
you know there's going to be one in your
robbery crew that's [__] it's
pre-recorded yeah what color shirt am I
wearing [__] it's real
um the new camera is also the only
indoor security camera that can trigger
the alarm and instantly deter Intruders
with a built-in siren and it's Advanced
motion detection and vision
uh AI can sense the difference between
potential Intruders and pets
oh God now you're going to get furries
are going to start robbing houses 24 7
live guard protection in the new Smart
Alarm indoor cameras uh Works seamlessly
as part of the entire Simply Safe
security system to keep your whole home
safe from break-ins fires flooring and
more with Simply Safe uh professional
monitoring costs under a dollar a day a
bargain for the for the peace of mind it
provides right now my listeners can get
20 off any Simply Safe system when you
sign up for fast monitoring this huge
offer is for a limited time visit
simplysafe.com that's simplysafe.com
um
all right well people I gotta wrap this
thing up because uh I got my ride coming
to go out to Allentown
and I'm going to find out what the [__]
Billy Joel was so goddamn excited about
why am I making fun of Billy Joel I love
Billy Joel
you know
you say I love you when I said I love
dance forever
um Liberty DeVito come on all right
that's the podcast everybody
um thank you so much for listening have
a wonderful weekend you [__] enjoy the
music picked out by the always fabulous
Andrew females and then we'll have a
bonus episode of the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast what's great about being up on a
roof there's no rats up here
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
the Monday Morning podcast for Monday
July 6th
2015. how [__] oh yeah
what's going on how was your weekend did
you have a good time did you blow off
your [__] fingers
um
did you enjoy the Fourth of July you
know first of all before right out of
the gate right out of the gate I want to
thank everybody that did some dumb [__]
with fireworks and had the presence of
mind to [__] make a YouTube video out
of it you know so guys like make it just
sit there I was laughing my house off
last night I went to bed and I was
watching people
shooting bottle rockets out of their ass
having Roman Candle fights seeing
somebody take one to the face do you
know some guy in Maine lit something off
on top of his [__] head and he died
instantly
they were like he let off they said some
a mortar
something [__] insane
what what kind of you know what kind of
a [__] [__] would do something
like that
he must have had it
there's no way
everybody knows once you get up to
anything like a pack of firecrackers on
your head you're like that's that's
funny
you're gonna [__] kill your eardrums
and you know but you're gonna survive
but what do you put in M80 in his mouth
or something
well I don't know Bill you [__]
brought it up all right relax let's just
look up main guy dies
fireworks
all right man shoots off Firework from
top of his head dies instantly a 22 year
old man was drinking and celebrating the
4th of July happy birthday to America
dude put it on my head happy birthday to
America oh [__]
ing happy birthday wow
Michael
oh my God somebody call it an ambulance
um that's how I went down
22 year old man who was drinking and
celebrating the Fourth of July tried to
launch a firework from top of his head
killing him instantly authorities said
Authority said you got to be an
authority to say that somebody's [__]
dead after they light something off on
their head
wait a minute wait a minute clear clear
the way yes yes he is dead well we kind
of knew that he has brains all over the
sidewalk watch your mouth woman
watch your mouth woman it's one of my
favorite quotes in sports over the last
[__] I don't know how many months six
months watch your mouth woman
when that woman called uh asked LeBron
what it was like to be a punk ass [__]
and then that guy's going watch your
mouth woman watch your mouth woman and
you know you would think that the broads
would have had such would have [__]
difficulty with it like you know I
realized that she said something
derogatory to towards him
self no excuse
go change your bra lady all right I love
that they didn't say anything because
even they knew even they knew that I got
it yeah that [__] was out of line
[Applause]
I'm just talking [__] today
um
they won't say what kind of firework it
was
all right apparently he thought that was
a great idea
that just when you died in a stupid
[__] way when somebody starts it off
when they start your eulogy off with
apparently
you know apparently this guy thought uh
sticking his head in the garbage
disposal was uh you know gonna give him
a good Buzz
I mean I'm sorry to bring it up Claire
but you know
how did it even get it in there
Hallelujah
um his friend said they thought
they thought they dissuaded him from
doing it the next thing they knew he
ignited the firework and he was killed
instantly what the [__] did he shoot off
there was no rushing him to the hospital
there was no Devon left when I got there
said 25 year old Cody
Jesus Christ the names of this
generation huh Devin Cody
Jeep Wrangler uh Devin was the kind of
person who would do something stupid
absolutely he was the kind of person who
would pretend to do something stupid to
make people laugh well he wasn't faking
it
um
all right it's the first fireworks
fatality since they legalized fireworks
January 1st 2012 well he just [__] it
up for the whole state
it's bad enough everyone's on heroin now
you're going to give them fireworks I
mean what next
does Isis get their own juice store
come on people
over 18 of bottle rockets are shot out
of people's anuses in this state alone
this needs to stop
that's going on in Main Street right now
in Maine
hi do you know me of course you don't
I'm your regular housewife here in Maine
my son is on heroin my other son shot a
Roman Candle up his ass I'm sorry to be
graphic he was trying to shoot it out of
his ass but apparently
is excitement
but who's getting who I mean in order to
light the wick you got to be able to see
it so
I don't know how these things were done
when we were kids we just we lit them
and we ran away we hid under our desks
that's what we did
Devin was a great person
um and in New Jersey a 52 year old man
blew off a large piece of his leg
below the knee when he set off a tennis
ball sized firework
in Montana
Montana
a 32 year old man was killed at his
Billings Home in a fireworks accident
involving a mortar tube
all right at least there was some sort
of mortar round I mean more around I
mean
first of all when you start lighting off
[__] where your neighbors starts
screaming and comment you know what what
do you think is going to happen
let's look up a mortar tube here
everybody I'm learning about fireworks
through the death of my fellow Americans
um
I spelled motor
all right
firework mortar tubes how about some
images let me see what the [__] these
things look like
is there some sort of
all right all I see is army guys
yeah that's not good
you know when when the [__] you're
shooting off
oh there we go
well there's one that looks like a
little Barbershop thing what a [__]
dope he shot that off his head
you know what probably happened I would
guess is that there was some sort of
discharge from the bottom end of it in
the concussive force but it seems like
there was no Devon he [__] blew his
head off
oh Jesus what a way to start I had such
a wonderful weekend
um I didn't mean this when I was talking
about funny [__] I was just talking
about you know people
having Roman Candle fights come on we
all did that [__] right
that's that is the evolution
of all weaponry
all right anything that has an explosive
device anything that that uh it's
explosive device anything that [__]
blow [__] up
you just you start
or you anything that you can shoot at a
Target it always starts simple
let's Light It Off
you know let's let's point it in that
direction at the trees
right
and then what then you move up to uh
let's torture some insects
uh let's shoot a bird
and eventually
because you know
the way human beings are that we always
try to top one another and we get bored
which is the reason why we went from
walking to the horse to the car I'm
really in deep right now I know I don't
know what the [__] I'm talking about
eventually you're going to move to the
the the ultimate prey the human being
you know
something that can think the same way
you do something that may have done
better in math than you did
you know that's the challenge this
person passed Algebra I did not
we're both trying to kill one another
is you know
first Outside Inside last gonna come
into play here we're when we're out in
the woods
our opposite angles being congruent
is that going to be the death of me or
do I just have
that extra something do I want it a
little bit more am I able to block out
the fifth commandment
do I have such a strong religious
background that I can hear God's voice
in my head telling me that I'm right
telling me to deliver
that animal it's not even a man anymore
it's a [__] animal deliver that
animal
in the express lane to its maker
right
do I have that I mean it's inevitable
that's personally why I don't [__] with
fireworks I don't [__] with fireworks
because I know that I am scatterbrained
and I get bored easily
and I have ten thousand [__] hobbies
and eventually lighting it off in the
driveway is not going to be enough for
me
okay I have neighbors I have neighbors
that I get along with
maybe I'm bored with the fact that I get
along with them maybe I want to stop
maybe some days you just wake up and you
just want to start some [__] and you
just happen to have some fireworks that
don't just blow up they they go way up
in the air
and you want to shoot somebody right
anyways uh my condolences to anybody uh
who knows somebody that died no I don't
have any condolences for the people that
died because you're [__] dead and
you're either dead or I think you're in
a better place because someone who's
dumb enough to blow themselves up on the
July 4th weekend with their own goddamn
explosives I don't think ever had the
brains to really hurt another human
being knowingly I never knowingly lied
knowingly hurt another [__] human
being
I mean honestly if you're that [__]
stupid obviously you could go out and
you could hurt somebody but you know
do you really have the mental capacity
to understand
you know your actions
man it's got to be one of the dumbest
[__] things you could ever do
take something of that level you know
what it is I really think it's the
[__] well they don't there's no video
of it
I was thinking this is the YouTube
generation where
you know everybody's basically on TV is
that [__] skinny blood disease to
[__] who painted The Soup cans that
everybody flipped out over Andy Warhol
one of the most overrated
overrated [__] artists of all time
all right I almost said I'm sorry but
I'm not sorry I'm not sorry that [__]
jerk off
drugging up people and banging them in
the ass and then [__] drawing a soup
can I mean if that's if that's an artist
in your world then you know what there's
a lot of artists in prison right now
they're [__] pasty jackass you know
he was the original hipster
you know
didn't have the balls to [__] strike
out
and do something new he just sort of
mocked
and just just by the way did anybody see
the last two episodes of the comedians
huh
did anybody
with Josh Gad and Billy Crystal I
[__] love that show and uh
this is a mini spoiler alert basically
Josh gets caught talking [__] about
Billy Crystal in his act
and uh then they still have to do they
got to do promos to do the upcoming stew
the fight that they [__] have
is great and um
Billy Crystal's character makes fun of
Josh's like [__] hipster friends
and such a [__]
just beautiful way eloquent way
and just really sums up that whole when
your creativity is just mocking whatever
exists it's such a [__] place to create
from
because at some point that's what I
always do whenever I watch somebody like
remember one time watching somebody that
went on on TV
and they just mock the art of stand up
you know which on on a certain level was
funny
was basically doing all the I don't know
what is what is the word in the industry
the tropes
the hacky [__] you know setups and
all that type of [__]
did all of that
but you know after a couple minutes it's
like okay I get it I get it there's some
tried and true [__] paths that you
can walk down as a comedian all right if
you're so Adept at seeing that [__] why
don't you show all of us the new road
and that's what those hipster [__]
never do they never they don't cut they
don't carve out any new ground they just
stomping all over [__] that's already
been done making fun of it so I actually
you know it's weird to me it's because
there's so much of that
during this period of time you know like
whenever in 20 years from now
when this generations of directors makes
their Fast Times at Ridgemont High
they're [__] uh Dazed and Confused
you know what I mean
actually Fast Times at Ridgemont High
took place in the 80s so that was
actually very current but I'm just
saying how you know in the 90s the 70s
became nostalgic and you made fun of all
the clothes and the [__] hairstyles
and all that in the 2000s and people
made fun of the 80s and now people kind
of mocking the 90s what are you gonna
mock now
people mocking the decades before like
that's what people did in this there's
got to be something
I know what they'll do let's see what
will they do they'll do uh DJ music
I'm being too hard on this generation
they got their own stuff they got math
every generation has to have their own
drug by the way you know
and heroin a little bit Old Something
Old Something New
Something Borrowed something blue right
so what do you do today they get the
meth
that's the new thing right the old
things heroin
Something Borrowed them mocking all this
[__] and something blue that's when they
[__] OD and they don't have any
Oxygen in their blood anymore
Jesus Christ Bill
what are you doing poetry over here
um
I'll tell you right now that was a solid
15 minutes and 15 seconds of absolute
horseshit and you know what you've sat
there and listened to it
that's what you're doing today
two days after the the [__] birthday
of America
when we kicked England's ass
Jesus Christ [__] England
isn't it amazing that that little ass
[__] Island that that was full of so
many [__] evil white people that they
could actually they actually kind of
took over the world for a while
well actually there was way less people
though wasn't there
you know most of the places they went to
you know
they they weren't uh
they weren't as advanced right this is
where a white guy gets in trouble for
saying some racist [__] you know what I
mean I'm not trying to say that you know
your boats weren't as good as their
boats I wasn't there okay and in a lot
of ways cultures that were considered
primitive if we continued to live that
way I want to ask you do you think that
the planet would be in the the the the
the polluted state that it is I don't
think it would be but I'll tell you this
right now I would already be dead
I would already be dead
you know
which for me selfishly I'm glad we
continue to advance and pollute the
[__] world
you know
but that's just a selfish [__] move
I should I should have said like you
know what I wish it stayed the same and
I died of a ruptured appendix when I was
12 years old
under a stack of blankets sweating in a
[__] Log Cabin Log Cabin too advanced
too many trees in a hut made out of the
skins of the animals that I ate
throughout my life my life I was gonna
say my lives my life
I was actually trying to think the eye I
was watching something the other day
and uh
I've been doing this weird thing where I
[__] start to nod off watching TV and
then I wake back back up again and then
I start thinking like did I just watch
that or did I just dream that and then I
always do the math and I was like that
is way too [__] up to have been on
television I must have just been
dreaming
and then I never have the presence of
mind
to [__] write it down
you know what I mean
I'll tell you would be [__] insane if
you could actually make a movie that
made people feel like they were dreaming
right
but you knew you were dreaming but you
couldn't wake up am I describing a coma
right now am I awake can you guys hear
me hear me hear me
um
the closest thing to that would be I
guess would be movies like Jacob's
Ladder Jacobs [__] letter
that movie was [__] that movie's still
great I watched that the other day very
underrated movie
starring uh the guy from Tim Robbins
the guy who used to be married to Susan
Sarandon oh crushed two names in a row
there
I saw Susan Sarandon recently in a movie
with uh
I want to say Melissa McCarthy
I don't even I don't remember all I know
is she was [__] hilarious oh it was
Melissa McCarthy
she was [__] hilarious
[__] hilarious
um as was Melissa as always so anyways
speaking of lady
Lady Luck Be A lady tonight
you won the ladies World Cup
you stuck that ball in the [__]
goal and you won the world club for the
third third [__] time
the [__] men haven't even won it once
it isn't fair
it is not right
why do only the ladies with the [__]
World Cup
while all the guys got their soccer
balls on Ice sorry
um the ladies World Cups I actually
[__] really got into it and by really
getting into it I kept forgetting it was
on but whenever I saw it I kept going
you know what I'm gonna watch this
I saw Japan versus Australia
Japan obviously won that one because
they played
the lady said the foil right
you know what
the [__] women had um
the women had what three goals in the
first four goals in like the first I
don't know how many minutes
like five minutes or something like that
I missed it of course
I was out uh what was I do I was playing
drums you know what I mean
I was doing that [__] and then I [__]
came back that's what I do I looked like
a [__] eight-year-old
I should have died when I was 12. what
am I doing here walking around like a
big kid you know I had to have a I
should have a [__] pacifier the way I
lived my [__] life everything else
weirdo guys
you know they can't let go of that
[__] childhood remember on Opie and
Anthony one time we were watching these
things then they [__] walk around
diapers and their mother treats him like
a big baby
Jesus Christ
you know what I mean
that's the one good thing if Hitler
lived the one good thing if Hitler lived
people who want to be adult babies would
would have been exterminated
[Music]
that's the only good thing that would be
the only time Hitler got it right
you know what I mean
that you take out child molesters and
you know beyond the shadow of the doubt
they're guilty you got the guy dead to
rights laying in a [__]
play pen playing with the mobile mobile
what are those [__] things that hang
over your head shell Exxon what do you
call those [__] things a mobile
a menorah
Minaj what the [__] is it called you
know what it is the things that hang
over and the kids look at it because
they're having like a [__] Acid trip
dude that would be the ultimate drug
don't worry ladies I'm gonna get back to
the women winning the soccer I got a lot
to say about that our football is they
call it around the world
that would be the ultimate [__] drug
is if you could take something that
erased temporary temporarily erased
everything you've ever learned in life
and you could go back to being a baby
again like the first time it opens its
eyes and you're just staring at a chair
like what in the [__] is that is that my
mother
is that edible you know what I mean
like because I heard
when babies first open their eyes it is
it's like an acid trip when they're
taking in all the colors light and every
they don't know what the [__] they know
what they [__] they don't want their
own hands are sit there staring at their
hand can you imagine
can you imagine the wonderment of that
that's why that's why babies need
diapers
because there's they're on such a trip
that you if you could [__] do that
and you looked at everything no you [__]
yourself because you don't you don't
even want to toilet is
he'd never been teased for shedding
yourself
you never even smelt the [__] you have
no [__] idea what it smells like
you just have to [__] and you [__]
you know what
that's how I do it right you're [__]
in the zone you're just burying threes
like Steph Curry except you hit all of
them where he only misses like two out
of a hundred but you bury all of them
because you don't know that it's [__]
practically impossible
tell you right now if I was running a
basketball team I'd sign a baby
you know get him up on his feet just get
him up on his feet okay keep feeding
this kid all right this is the new
triangle offense okay we got the [__]
baby right at the point we're gonna keep
feet keep working it around to him all
right
and and kid kid over here hey
yeah over here you just keep launching
it everybody under the [__] room just
keep [__] throwing it up right be
like when the Nuggets decided not to
play defense and they thought that they
were gonna have the first 200 point game
what am I talking about ah [__] you I
got an hour to fill here I don't have
any [__] advertising copy so this is
just going to be me just running my
[__] Yap for as long as I can
um
all right so back to the ladies the
ladies of women's soccer
the soccer playing human beings that
have the the lady bits
all right
um so they scored four goals of course I
missed all the [__] goals the only
goal it was four to one the only goal I
saw was when Japan all of a sudden cut
it to four to two and I was like oh [__]
is this like NHL hockey where no lead is
safe anymore and then the ladies came
right back down and gave Japan the old
right there Fred they gave me all right
there Fred bam shut the [__] up go home
go home crying because you just lost
all right now
let's look I actually this out into what
a sports nerd I am even a sport that I
don't even admittedly do not even watch
or don't watch it nearly as much as I
should because it is a beautiful sport
especially the way the women play it I
actually prefer women's soccer to men's
soccer why you say over there in Jolly
Old England
Ireland or with [__] Argentina Brazil
Germany all this [__] soccer
Giants football I'll tell you why I
prefer it because the women don't dive
every three seconds crying like a bunch
of babies
when the women go down like they [__]
you know
they got tripped up and then they look
at the ref like what the [__] you gonna
call that
I thought the women played you know they
play a better game they just play a
better [__] game I'm sure the men's
is a little faster [__] blah blah
blah blah but all the goddamn [__]
whining and crying in men's soccer I
tell you right now men's football
players you got to be ashamed of
yourself and that goes for you too
they're [__] Rooney or whatever your
[__] name is there on Man United
all right
looking like [__]
I don't want the [__] what
champ sport whatever the [__]
character's name is
sorry all right let's let's just [__]
plow we had here yeah
the women don't [__] cry every two
seconds but I will tell you this what is
[__] funny is when they lost Japan's
goalie
just started crying
I mean the defense sucks the defense had
a total [__] meltdown I don't know
what when the ladies
coach saw
but whatever it was they exploited it
[__] three times in the first five
minutes and the only bad goal was when
they they actually shot one from center
ice
and uh the goalie looked like me playing
right field when I was in fourth grade
like oh it's gonna it could have been
for a single
remember that when you totally misjudged
it second hits the bat you start running
in towards the first baseman and then I
don't know
and it's not within three steps you do
that [__] just immediate stop
and all of a sudden your head's back at
a 45 degree angle as that ball just
keeps going up over your head that's
what she did and what's funny is she
leaped up in the air with the one hand
to try to stop it
and when it went over her head she just
[__] landed
on her entire backside and you could
already see her just going [__] and in
the end of the game
I guess she felt that she cost her team
the victory which she didn't it was
absolutely horrific
defense she just bursted out crying
which is one of the beautiful things
about being a woman
you know when you look at a baby all
right boy or girl you know they want
something you know that's yours
something of value and you take it away
so you can't have that and they want it
they immediately just
start [__] crying
they're upset they don't like what's
happened and they immediately they just
cry it out
women can do that
women can do that and you feel bad for
them if a man cries another man the only
thing you can do is just laugh in their
face and tease them until they stop
doing it because it makes you so [__]
uncomfortable as a man
the only time it's acceptable is uh when
your friend blows his head off with a
mortar
round whatever the [__] he did at uh
yeah
you know
and a Fourth of July party and even then
even then you know you gotta shake it
off within a couple of Miller Highlights
there
you know all right Cliff he's dead okay
it's not going to bring him back we've
still got all these Bears what is the
difference if we say it now or in the
morning
he's going to be just as dead in the
morning we're running out of ice we got
to finish these things and you're like
you're right man you're right sorry
you know it's just like why would he do
that
sorry
um
Jake that's the thing about women they
can just [__] cry
and we're not allowed to and it's that
combination that they are allowed to cry
out their pain and we have to hold on to
it and the fact that they then turn
around and nag the [__] [__] out of
us that they actually take 10 years off
our lives do you realize that if women
died 10 years before men did you can you
imagine how much they'd be complaining
about that how much they would be
blaming us for it
you know when we say that we die you
know men die 10 years early they just
blame us well you know you don't you
hold on to your emotions you don't go to
the doctor
yeah and what about the [__] Factor
huh anything there can you if I swear to
God if you turn the [__] tables and
women died an average of 10 years before
men did all right what color what pansy
color uniform would the NFL players have
to wear for an entire [__] month as
they raised awareness how much would
they be blaming us how many movies would
Meryl Streep win an Oscar for playing
the woman that was strong enough to die
at the same time as the guy in her life
huh
I don't know you know what's funny about
guys in the beauty of guys is we still
we don't even give a [__] we died 10
years sooner than you do and we don't
even give a [__]
it's the beauty of the simplistic man
brain
um anyways let's plow ahead here
uh so Women's World Cup soccer has been
around since 1991.
and as of yesterday the United States of
America we've won the most
we've won three
once Germany has won two Einstein
strikes Norway has won one
in the death metal capital of the world
and Japan has won one
Japan actually won the last one so we
dethroned the Champions all right
um men's World Cup soccer
there's only been so wait wait Women's
World Cup soccer there's only been five
six seven times it's been played
all right this is why I'm finally
gaining respect for this I always get
had respect for the championship because
the entire world does compete but not
only does the whole world compete they
do it every four years so it's really it
really [__] means something here
and all these people around the world
who are going like yeah bill you dumb
[__] yank yeah it means something
well you know what maybe if you guys
want a bunch of [__] girls flopping
all over the [__] place and you could
actually pick it up with your hands
I don't understand a sport where you
have four [__] Limbs and you're only
allowed to use two of them
Jesus Christ it's like it's like it's
like you're mocking the handicap the
entire time I'm watching the [__]
game
anyways sorry
so there's there's only been 20.
men's World Cups all right
Brazil is won the most at five
Italy and Germany have both won four and
I got to give the nod to Germany as much
as I love Italians
the way they dress their food
their flashy [__] jewelry I'm all
about it
I love Italians and I am [__] German
I Gotta Give the nod to Germans because
they won their first three with half a
[__] country
they won their first one let's let me
look this up let me make sure that I
have this correct
um they won their first one I think in
1954.
I mean that's literally like
what is that like
about nine almost less than a decade
yeah they've won their first one in 1954
World War II ended in 45 46 something
like that
1944 Maybe
we'll say 45. what the [__] within nine
years of trying to take on the entire
world
and losing
Dresden and bombs all over the [__]
place they they won a World Cup with
half their country West Germany
you know what I mean I'm sure East
Germany was actually in it too
who's getting who Germany's just I mean
that is just a roid Factory over there
1974 they won it
they were they were on they were on they
were doing so many steroids by 1974.
that uh a lot of people don't know this
that West Germany team was actually 80
uh women a lot of people don't know that
East Germany East German women
you know
they were so rated up they didn't have
to sneak out of the country
they just stared down the people in the
guard Tower and they were just like hey
man I don't want any problem bro
all you all you you want me to open that
gate for you okay
um 1990 they wanted
all right let's get back to what the
[__] I was talking about here
um
where the hell did it go oh there we go
all right Uruguay has won to Argentina
hand of God
one two
and then England France and Spain have
all won one
and that is it
it's only been won 20 times and one two
three four five six seven eight
countries only eight countries have won
it so now I feel better
that the u.s's men's have never won a
[__] World Cup
you know most people giving a [__] it's
like well how many did you [__] win
you've never won it either and I love
that I now know who's won it and who
hasn't so if I ever walk into a soccer
sports bar I know who I can talk [__] to
and who I can't to
what are you huh you from Brazil oh
Chile oh go [__] yourself you ever went
[__] either
what's your big what's your big feather
in your cap that you care
um which makes the women winning three
all the more impressive but you got to
give it up to Germany
Germany is uh the only country
that has won both
the men and the worlds and and the
women's and they've won four men's and
they've won two women's
and they're only off by one in both you
gotta respect that
Jesus Christ
when is Brian Gumbel Real Sports gonna
be doing a what's in the water what's in
the water over there in [__] Germany
you know why they're not going to do it
because we have a base over there we
already know what's in the water a big
vat of [__] steroids I gotta tell you
it's amazing
you know
to watch Germany
Channel all their hatred for other races
and nationalities and and put it into
something more productive like sports
and look at the success that they've had
you know what I mean
that burning
passion
to incinerate people that aren't that
don't look like them the fact that we've
been sitting on their [__] chest for
the last 60 years they've had to to to
Focus that energy in different areas and
they are dominating the world game of
soccer football whatever and look at the
cars that they make
it's incredible if you've noticed all
the fascist countries make the greatest
cars Germany
[__] Italy
who else
Finland they don't make good cars they
make good phones for a minute
but look at them Angry Birds they made
those Angry Birds
you know what I mean
all of a sudden they couldn't
exterminate the people they didn't want
to exterminate in their country what did
they do they said all right what are we
going to do with all this hate
I want to like to make some phones I'm
sorry I can't do a [__] [__] thin
accent actually I give Finland a pass
for being down with the h-bomb and uh in
World War II
I uh you know what were they supposed to
do you know what I mean this [__] was
like all right where we are
geographically
you look to the right you got Adolf
Hitler with beads of sweat his beady
eyes and his [__] eyebrows are you
with us or are you against us right and
on the other side they got uh Eastern
Europe's Tom Selleck the one and only
Joseph Stalin or Joseph if you're a
history buff
staring you down right this [__]
would sacrifice a hundred thousand
Russians every day just so he could have
fresh pineapple juice I mean this guy
was a [__] Maniac they were they were
between
two they were stuck between two of the
biggest psychos
in the history of of in modern history
all right so they had to go with
self-preservation
all right Hitler Stalin equally out of
their [__] minds all right so that's
a wash
what's the next thing all right let's go
with technology German cars what do we
got what do we got going on here they
got the Mercedes-Benz they got the
Duesenberg did they make the dusenberg I
don't know what the [__] they had they
had [__] them they know they got they
got they got uh
they're making eight-track tapes over
here [__] 50 years before they got 40
years 30 years before the [__] Bee
Gees
what are we supposed to do here they got
real real machines you go over to Russia
what do they got they got Vodka
they got a goddamn [__] car made with
a lawnmower engine spitting out Blue
Smoke
and they you know they got you know they
got those chicks with the [__] Lao
Alzado arms
you know by the way Russian women have
really come around huh
Jesus Christ they're [__] gorgeous
now back in the day
during the Cold War maybe those are the
only women that they showed us
they all had those [__] Popeye the
Sailor Man [__] forearms
you know what I mean from throwing
calves over some [__]
Hill they weren't supposed to run over
so whatever so Finland goes you know
what [__] it
we're going with the h-bomb
all right
flashlight
gas Chambers they [__] went with this
Maniac what were they supposed to do
they [__] picked the wrong guy and
you know what's funny was Russia
actually attacked Finland and Finland
kicked their [__] ass with no help
from the Germans as far as what I
overheard in bars in Finland
and this is the funny thing but they
went down with the ship
with the h-bomb over there right they
went down with that guy who [__]
pussied out and killed himself in the
end
this [__] broad
rather than going out like Saddam
Hussein
talking [__] as they put the Rope around
your neck
even people Heck on you still you still
had them on their heels
huh for me that's like uh
like when you know when people bring up
uh Comics getting [__] heckled and
that type of [__] and people like to
watch it the ultimate one like if I was
a dictator I would be looking at how
Saddam was saying when I'd be like this
[__] here right there right
and everybody oh what about Hitler you
know he killed all those people like
that's probably respected with [__]
you know dictators like that's how many
HBO specials you had like how many
[__] people you killed they but you
know all evil people are going like ah
man like his [__] amazing numbers
that he had it's like yeah but he went
out like a [__]
you know he went out like a [__] just
like Gaddafi went out like a [__]
pleading for his [__] life
Saddam Hussein walked right up going
yeah go [__] yourself [__] you I'm gonna
come back I want to hunt you right
he [__] stared them all down he
didn't give a [__]
standing there stepped onto that thing
no one at any second they could pull the
[__] lever he wasn't even shaking
he'd be staring them all down go [__] he
wasn't even nervous to meet his maker
that's one of the sickest things I've
ever seen in my life
um
what am I talking about so they [__]
they beat they beat the goddamn Russians
but because they they picked the wrong
guy
you know what I mean that's like when
you're in the wrong division in baseball
you have like back in the day
you know you'd have a better or when
that year when the Patriots won 11-5
but they didn't make the [__]
playoffs
that's what that's what [__] Finland
did and they actually had to give away
even though they beat the Russians they
then had they still had to give him some
land how [__] up is that
oh War all right I hope some of that was
even just remotely historically accurate
I have no idea as long as it was
entertaining did it entertain you all
right so anyways I had an amazing
weekend I had an amazing weekend
um
I uh
you know I had some family uh came in
and for the first time ever I uh I gave
a helicopter ride to some
family members I went up with the
[__] uh instructor though because I'm
not a [__] but we did this great flight
uh we flew out of Long Beach
we ran around the palace Verdes
Peninsula it's great man you fly right
over the Queen Mary
and then you go around the peninsula and
as you go around the peninsula that's
when you start realizing how many
goddamn things are in the ocean even
though we [__] fished them out and we
started going along the beach and I
thought they were dolphins and my
instructors going no those are actually
baby great great white sharks they just
haven't reached the predatory stage yet
and I swear to God there was like five
of them
um
and there was one and there's all these
people frolicking in the [__] water
and there was this one jackass who had
swam Beyond where they were
um they were perpendicular to him but he
was further out into the ocean they were
closer to the beach I wouldn't explain
this correctly and he was swimming out
to like a buoy like that naked chick in
the beginning of Jaws
um yeah
said it a million times you're out of
your [__] mind if you swim in the
ocean if you don't believe me take a
helicopter ride have them fly a hundred
feet off the [__] ocean I know what
you're thinking Bill what Jesus Christ
what you how [__] nuts yeah they have
a 2200 hour [__] overall it's a brand
new helicopter every 2200 hours go [__]
yourself what I'm doing is infinitely
more safe all right
um and then we uh made a right turn at
the ferris wheel
on Santa Monica Piers we flew over Santa
Monica over Beverly Hills right over
[__] Aaron the Aaron Spelling Mansion
which is the most ridiculous house ever
built that I can think of do you know
that house was so big I saw a thing one
time they did it on the Aaron Spelling
house they actually have a room in there
just for wrapping gifts
to have a gift wrapping room
you know what I mean
to me I always thought that for the
people who do American Horror Story like
that would be a great place to do one of
those things people that are that level
[__] rich and then somehow the the
children and the poor people that put
together all the things that they wrap
in there somehow come and haunt them I
have no idea but feel free to send that
to the producers over there so they can
[__] laugh you out of the goddamn
room
um
and who doesn't like watching a [__]
rich person get haunted and die a
horrific death I mean that's just fun I
mean that's a [__] home run right
there American Horror Story
you know
you don't have to give me any money all
I ask is if you use it just give the
Monday Morning podcast a [__] shout
out that's all
that's all just have somebody tell
somebody else to go [__] themselves and
have them wearing an orange wig and I'll
be happy right there that that'll be
enough for me
um all right plowing ahead here uh and
the Playboy Mansion is right to the left
of it and we flew up um
to the Hollywood side over the
observatory did a lap around Dodger
Stadium and then my favorite part ever
we flew up Route 2 bang the left up and
over the hill and where is it
a granddaddy of them all flew over the
[__] Rose Bowl
and then went right back to right down
back down to uh Long Beach
um was [__] awesome man we flew in
what's called an r44 Robinson 44.
someday you know what I mean someday I
want to get one of those
when I get a little more uh confident
and I also have
the kind of money to blow on a [__]
helicopter
I imagine I'll have to drug my wife on
some level there's a lot of there's a
lot of you know variables
as a man to buying a helicopter like the
amount of [__]
money and and
hand as they said on Seinfeld the amount
of hand that you got to have hand in a
relationship that you'd have to have to
actually [__] justify buying a
helicopter when you really have nowhere
to go in the thing
so anyways
don't get a used one on [__]
Craigslist
damn things are awesome
um all right so guess what
last night
was my last cigar and my last I'm taking
a booze break Oh Billy clean cakes is
back in the house I got a nice round
white belly
from uh you know grilling drinking I had
a great [__] weekend and I manned my
own Grill
manned my own Grill as a man does even
if you don't know how to do it even if
you you risk giving the people at your
party E coli
it doesn't make a difference you are a
man
and you [__] you man your own goddamn
Grill
um I I kept it simple I just made
burgers and and uh hot dogs and what's
[__] amazing is we got this butcher
um in the next neighborhood over from us
and they make their own
you can order homemade hamburger buns
and hot dog buns they made us like it
the hot dog buns they came in like uh
it looked like ribs except they were hot
dog buns and you had to cut them to
separate them and then cut them again to
make them you know to split them so you
put the hot dog in it was [__] I felt
like it was like the 1920s or some [__]
you know what I mean everything was
homemade and boy oh boy was it
refreshing
um
so anyways uh let's get to uh let's get
to some of the questions here
um for this week yes so I am I am
announcing it on the [__] podcast
because uh that I am not drinking or
smoking or anything like that so I will
stick so you guys will hold me to it so
I don't have to hang my head in shame
next week and tell you that I [__] up
all right
so oh here we go I finally got my
advertising here for this week it was a
little bit late
um all right
all right here we go what do we got here
I'm coming up on an hour
all right uh quote [__] bill is a mom
of three count them three mentally
challenged kids
uh what you have my permission to use
the word whenever you want to describe
idiots at your show I don't want
permission I don't want to use the word
I don't want to hurt people okay but I
reserve the right to every once in a
while if I flip out and I drop the
[__] word
in a moment of anger because I'm
standing there in front of a [__]
drunk who won't shut up
I still expect you to give me [__] about
it but just accept my apology and know
that I don't have anything against
mentally challenged people I just was
pissed at this person
and I made a mistake that's all I'm
asking I'm not asking for a license to
use the word I don't want to use it
Jesus all right
orzo response to mentioning orzo last
week orzo last week
uh uh red Bill gives you wings hey
there's a new one
uh tell that woman of yours to get back
in the goddamn kitchen orzo is a pasta
shape
shaped like rice not a grain Christ
alive but seriously love Nia her
appearances are the best part of the
podcast well [__] you I like to think I
bring something to the table
um oh that's great I'll have to let her
know that
orzo is a pasta
pasta shape is pasta oh Jesus Christ
orzo is pasta shaped like rice
dude I really have a [__] learning
disability man I can't read words
I can read them I just can't put them to
I said it's a
I said orzo is pasta shaped rice
I don't know what the [__] I said orzo
is pasta shaped like rice
you know what
anybody who listens to this podcast has
got to be at least as dumb as I am let
me [__] look this up maybe they're
right
orzo
orzo up Wikipedia says it's pasta see
you gotta you gotta think it's true
orzo it's Italian for Bali from the
Latin also Rison is a form of shortcut
pasta shaped like a large grain of rice
orzo can be served alone as a soup
accoutrement
as part of a salad
or pilaf
or geovesti or baking a casserole what's
geovastity I want to go to Italy I want
to go I want to go to Florence
oh Jesus look at what the Italians are
the best man what the oh that's Greek my
apologies I want to go to Greece I don't
go to Greece right now
hey
I didn't I didn't even see how the [__]
did they vote did they vote to [__]
let their their
goddamn Banks just fail
that's what they should do they should
just let everything fail and then then
everybody's money isn't worth [__] and
then you know something those Bankers
got to come out in public and then you
[__] stab them in the gut like that
dude at the beginning of Scarface
all right
uh
Greece
vote let's see well come on man come on
Greece you know they didn't
Market's resilient after no vote uh and
we always [__] out we always [__]
everybody always ends up pussying out
you know something only [__] Iceland
has had the balls to stand up to their
[__] bankers and you know what I hope
I'm wrong about that and if I am please
tell me who else has all right no idea
where to start Dear Mr Burr
I'm a 16 year old high school junior
from a rural town in Mississippi just a
good old boy
never meaning no harm
getting a Confederate a red flag
birthday cake every [__] six months
cause his parents are too dumb to know
what a year is
you're not even 16 buddy you're really
[__] eight sorry that was totally
stereotypical and I shouldn't have done
that now that I'm nearing my final year
of high school and will soon be having
to decide where to go to college
I've realized I have no idea what I want
to do with my life the only two things I
have interest in is writing and stand-up
comedy well those are two phenomenal
things you can make a hell of a living
I've flunked everything in high school
but here's a few places from where I
live but there's a few places from where
I live where I could do something like
an open mic
Jesus Christ but you know something this
should inspire you right right here how
awful
I am at reading out loud yet I've been
able to do something in this business
you know what I mean I'm able to make a
living and and I can put Frosted Mini
Wheats on the table
for my family of one
um the only two things I have interest
in is writing stand upon but there's few
places from where I live where I could
do something like an open mic
or get honest opinions on my comedic
writing I'm writing to ask where in your
opinion would be a great town for
starting for starting communion to start
uh also if you think someone can juggle
College in a stand-up do you think
someone can juggle stand up in a call uh
College in a stand-up career I would
truly be grateful for your advice and
also go [__] yourself
um
all right
any place is a good place to start just
start if there's an open mic I would
drive
as long as I had to drive to go to it
um let's see you're in Mississippi
all right what do I what do I know about
down there
I mean the closest scene that I know of
from Mississippi Atlanta Nashville uh uh
Texas
Houston was always a great comedy town I
don't know what the open mic scene is
like if anybody anybody any comedians
out there start now
anybody anything going on in Alabama
what's going on in Mississippi
right in give this kid some [__]
advice uh tweet me about it I'll retweet
it that's the easiest way to do it
because we might not see your emails
because we get a bunch of them so just
tweet me about it and uh
you know at Bill Burr on Twitter and um
if you got some good advice I will
retweet it
um
can you juggle College in a stand-up
career yeah absolutely
absolutely
um
you can do whatever you want to do in
life dude you can do whatever you want
that's the one [__] thing everybody
you know
you know because people want to make it
they try to look at what is working for
the most people and then they they get
locked into that that's the biggest
advice I can give you is do not get
locked in
to what everybody else is doing get
locked into what's going on in your
[__] chest whatever that thing's
saying like do this unless it's saying
to shoot your neighbor don't do that but
if it's you're doing something that's
not going to hurt somebody like writing
jokes telling them writing a script yeah
you can do whatever the [__] you want to
do and the fact that you're 16 and
you're already are listening to yourself
you're way ahead of the game so
um
and you have the
intelligence to understand that you know
hey I need some help and you reached out
for it keep doing that
my friend and I hope to see you out
there give it a shot
you know but I would I would I'd write
five minutes of [__] tonight and then
sign up for an open mic somewhere and
within the week I would start
do it and that's unbelievable balls to
be able to do that at 16. it took me
almost to 24 to get the balls to do it
so my hat is off to you sir or ma'am
like I don't know who you are all right
here we go girlfriend has prejudiced
parents a Billy Billy dingleberry I am a
white man who's dating a black woman she
is the greatest thing that has ever
happened to me and there's no doubt in
my mind that I want to spend my life
with her well congratulations until now
we've been dating for 10 months and I
finally met our parents this past
weekend when I got there they seemed
shocked by my skin color almost like my
girl hadn't even hinted to them that I
was white well that's probably what
happened if they are [__] racist
um the whole dinner was very awkward I
wasn't being looked at in the eye and I
was left out of most of the conversation
didn't they make a movie about this
Ashton Kutcher in the late great Bernie
Mac I even tried talking to her dad
about music since we are both musicians
but he just kept giving me short answers
like he didn't give a [__] after the
whole thing was over my girlfriend said
that they didn't like that I was white
uh she said that they wanted her to have
strong black babies and not to dilute
the bloodline
uh they spouted a bunch of other [__]
about how much trouble we'll run into
was an interracial couple it has been
four days and we still haven't talked
about it nor has she told her parents
off for being prejudiced [__] I
truly believe this is the only situation
where a white person can fully
understand what a black person well I
don't know about that dude wait you get
you get you get a little sprinkling of
it uh a black guy with a microphone on
the street corner could call me Cracker
all he wants and I won't lose a wink of
Sleepover but when you're told
uh the person you love is wrong and
invalid that's like a kick in the balls
anyways how should I go about addressing
this
I'm assuming he did run this problem
with Nia no I didn't make maybe she
could weigh in on this as well anyway
thanks and go [__] yourself
ah Jesus
um I was if you love her I would stay
with her if if you questioning it I'd
pull the rip cord because that's just
gonna be a [__] nightmare that'll end
up being a nightmare you know what I
mean you're gonna be in a relationship
where you're waiting for the other
person's parents to die sitting there
going like one down
the two day you know that's just a
[__] up you know you really when
you're gonna get married is you have to
uh
I don't know I mean who the [__] am I to
say I waited so goddamn long so I'm not
an authority but
you know
if you if you're with somebody that's
fun
you know and they come from a good
family and their family supported of you
guys I mean that's so much of the battle
actually you know something this past
week when I was in Vegas somebody came
up to me and said hey Bill let me I got
to ask you a question who makes you
laugh and without even thinking I said
my wife and it made me feel really good
like ah it's great you know my wife's a
hot [__] she makes me laugh we have a
good time
um
and uh so
I don't know she might not be bringing
it up because she's embarrassed about it
or whatnot
[Music]
um
I have no idea but uh
I mean that's gonna be a hell of a
[__] situation
if that's how they're gonna view their
grandkids I mean that's kind of uh
that that's a major [__] situation
where I would at least
want to see where her head is at and
then you throw out certain scenarios
about the future so how are we going to
handle this and blah blah blah
um
you know what uh sorry going through
that dude but you definitely need to
have some [__] conversations I would
think
I would definitely think some
conversations are written order all
right Colin Farrell movies
hey Billy [__]
uh Colin Farrell has done a couple of
great movies since phone booth you
should that you should like namely
in brudges bruegas I don't know how to
say it and Seven Psychopaths with the
always excellent Sam Rockwell oh Jesus
Christ
I got a C7 seven psycho Seven
Psychopaths I gotta see that
um
you could give you could give them a
look
all right coming to California next year
from Ireland on holiday
I hope to see you in action all right
well I hope you make it out to a show
all right yeah
so I got hit with a wave of [__]
tired all right that's the podcast of
this week go [__] yourselves and uh I'll
be checking in on you on Thursday all
right see you